>>>, SO A FAMILY IN TEXAS IS
BATTLING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OVER PLANS TO
TAKE PART OF THEIR LAND THROUGH
AN EMINENT DOMAIN ORDER.
>> THE FIGHT ACTUALLY BEGAN LAST
YEAR WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND THE FAMILY
FEARS THE GOVERNMENT WILL USE
THE LAND TO BUILD A BORDER WALL.
SOMETHING THEY DO NOT WANT TO
SEE.
CNN'S NICK VALENCIA HAS THE
STORY.
>> Reporter: SO, THIS LETTER IS
FROM THE GOVERNMENT TELLING YOU
THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO BUILD
A WALL HERE?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
>> Reporter: FRED AND HIS COUSIN
DON'T WANT A BORDER WALL.
FOR YEARS UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THEY FOUGHT IN
COURT TO STOP THEIR FAMILY LAND
FROM BEING SEIZED BY EMINENT
DOMAIN TO BUILD ONE.
THERE'S A PORTION OF THE WALL TO
THE EAST OF THEIR PROPERTY AND
ANOTHER PORTION OF THE WALL TO
THE WEST.
NOW THIS ROUGHLY ONE-MILE
STRETCH ON THEIR FAMILY'S LAND
IN BETWEEN IS ABOUT TO BE FILLED
UP BY EVEN MORE BORDER WALL.
>> THERE WILL NOT BE ANOTHER
FOOT OF WALL CONSTRUCTED ON MY
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Reporter: JOE BIDEN RAN TO BE
PRESIDENT IN PART ON HIS PROMISE
TO STOP A WALL FROM BEING BUILT
ALONG THE U.S./MEXICO BORDER,
BUT THIS MAN AND HIS FAMILY SAY
BIDEN LIED.
>> AT FIRST HE SAID, NO, NO, NOT
ONE MORE FOOT.
NOW HE'S THINKING ABOUT MILES.
>> Reporter: TWO WEEKS AGO, A
FEDERAL JUDGE RULED THAT 6 1/2
ACRES OF THE FAMILY'S 60-ACRE
PROPERTY WILL BE TAKEN FROM
THEM, AND THERE'S NOTHING THEY
CAN DO ABOUT IT.
>> IT MAKES YOU THINK, WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE LIVING IN A FREE
COUNTRY AND MAKES ME THINK, YOU
KNOW, ARE WE THAT FREE?
>> THIS IS WHERE THE WALL WOULD
GO.
>> Reporter: EMINENT DOMAIN
ALLOWS THE GOVERNMENT TO ACQUIRE
PRIVATELY OWNED LAND FOR PUBLIC
USE.
FOR THIS FAMILY, THAT MEANS
THEY'LL LOSE A PIECE OF THEIR
FAMILY HISTORY.
WHAT'S WORSE, THEY SAY, IS WHAT
THE LAND WILL BE USED FOR.
ACCORDING TO THE ORIGINAL ORDER
THAT WAS FILED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, IT'S LIKELY TO
BE USED TO BUILD A WALL AND ADD
ADDITIONAL BORDER
INFRASTRUCTURE, LIKE THIS BORED.
ER PATROL SURVEILLANCE TOWER AND
BORDER PATROL GUARD STATION THAT
CURRENTLY SITS ON THEIR
PROPERTY.
>> WHAT I WANT FROM PRESIDENT
BIDEN IS TO STOP THE WALL.
KEEP HIS WORD.
HE SAID, NO MORE WALLS, NOT ONE
FOOT OF WALL.
AND NO MORE LAND CONFISCATIONS.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT HIM TO DO IS
KEEP HIS WORD.
>> Reporter: IN A STATEMENT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SAID, IT
SOUGHT CONTINUANCES AND PENDING
CASES, INCLUDING IN THIS CASE,
IN WHICH THE GOVERNMENT HAD
PREVIOUSLY FILED MOTIONS FOR
POSSESSION OF LAND ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
RIGHT BEFORE THE RESCHEDULED
HEARING IN THIS CASE, THE JUDGE
GRANTED THE DOJ'S MOTION THAT
HAD BEEN FILED UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
WHEN ASKED IF THEY WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO KEEP THEIR LAND,
DESPITE THE JUDGE'S RULING, THE
DOJ DID NOT RESPOND.
ROBERTO LOPEZ IS PART OF THE
LEGAL TEAM REPRESENTING THE
CAVAZOS FAMILY.
>> THIS IS ONE OF 140 DIFFERENT
CASES ACROSS THE STATE OF TEXAS.
NOW, NOT EVERYONE IS IN POSITION
LIKE THE CAVASOS FAMILY IS, BUT
THEY COULD BE VERY WELL SOON.
>> I HAVE AN EMOTIONAL
ATTACHMENT TO THIS LAND BECAUSE
I WORKED IT ALL THROUGH MY
YOUTH, SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE -- WE WANT TO KEEP IN THE
FAMILY.
WE DON'T WANT TO GET RID OF IT.
THERE'S NO AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY
COULD GIVE US FOR THE LAND RIGHT
NOW THAT WOULD WARRANT US -- THE
PEOPLE THAT OWN THIS LAND
SELLING IT.
>> Reporter: THE FAMILY SAYS THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT OFFERED AROUND
$347,000 IN COMPENSATION, BUT TO
THEM, THIS LAND IS PRICELESS.
THEY ARE AN ESTIMATED 140
FAMILIES ALONG THE U.S./MEXICO
BORDER AT RISK OF HAVING THEIR
LAND SEIZED BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT OR ALREADY HAD THEIR
LAND SEIZED.
THERE'S LITT